the jogan experience I feel like there's
like a backlash happening you know I
feel like it's interesting like being
pregnant you really I've started getting
like obsessed with you know everything
you put in your body you know and just
the idea of just drinking water is like
a full-time job like where am I getting
my water right I got it because it's
either my choices are
fluoride or microplastics and I'm not
I'm not having a baby with a small taint
I'm telling you that right now yeah do
you have did you ever check yourself for
phalates while you were [__] no no where
do I do that too late I did the tally
age test the biological age oh phalates
are microplastic it's like chemicals
that leech out of plastics I mean I for
sure got them well everybody has them no
way I don't yeah there was a study that
they did recently it was like what is it
what was the number like 90 something
per of people had thetes in their body
something nuts also there's this um this
guy I don't want to uh plagiarized his
work Kashif Khan he wrote that DNA way
book about how their micro uh the
forever chemicals in women's yoga pants
oh right in the crotch it's in
AstroTurf how about [__] baby powder
dude we used to put it in our underwear
before basketball games 50 there's been
50,000 lawsuits uh they've paid I think
over eight or nine billion which is
probably nothing to them but women
getting uh ovarian cancer from uh the T
asbest in it and then also the miners of
the talc yes yeah that's what I was
reading that talc and its best are often
in the same spot and they don't filter
it out well to what like they don't even
test to see if the tal has Theus in it
sometimes Johnson and Johnson's gotten
away with some wild [__] well that's a
wild one I just how did they
know what I want to know is did they
know like did they know that sometimes
their tal has as best as in it it was
just too problematic to sift it out and
figure out what's what what is the deal
with that find out what's the deal with
like think the miners definitely
complain my guess is it is a similar
trajectory to the oh here it is because
talc and his bestus are minerals found
close together when talc is mined it may
contain traces of as bestas talcum
powder is still an ingredient in a
number of cosmetic brands as recently as
November of 2020 a study found that 14%
of the toal containing makeup tested
contained asbestos that's
wild can I tell you a lot of my
girlfriends when they act insane I act I
ask a couple questions like what birth
control contr are you on and what hair
products and makeup are you using cuz
you're just putting chemicals and I mean
your Skin's your biggest organ right
you're just the amount of chemicals
women just put on their bodies in their
bodies they knew for decades that it's
best has lurked in its baby powder oh my
God
unreal that's crazy this is Reuters I
want to say it was in St Louis but they
it was over 50,000 lawsuits oh my God
that's so crazy Johnson Johnson didn't
tell the FDA that at least three tests
by three three different Labs from 72 to
75 it found aestus in his talc in one
case that levels reported as rather High
who says
rather who says rather in that
context what kind of you know what kind
of numbers are we talking about they
were rather high high the thing that
really freaks me out is even natural
remedies are starting to be bought up by
these corporations so you know brags
apple cider vinegar uh Bill Gates bought
it oh God Bill Gates now owns one of the
few natural
healthy tonics we had and he's putting
the apples in it with oh the appeal the
appeal the creepy ass oh what is that
that's like a coating that they spray on
the outside of vegetables it's like some
SCH smegma to keep the apples uh
preserved longer is it just apples he
just so obsessed that he didn't invent
Apple computers he's just like just
poisoning everything apples he just has
to but yeah it's like to for Costco
apples to stay fresher longer but what
is in it I would love to know
I would love to know these [__]
they can they get stuff out there before
anybody's aware that these things are a
problem and then like years later you're
like what's in it tal asbest and then
you don't find out till later so it's
like talking about this and just being
like being suspicious about like [__]
apples last for four weeks I feel like
bill needs a hug like why are you
working so hard did you see the video of
him against trees what Bill Gat look up
Bill Gates against oh he thinks he
should bury all the trees he's like I
don't plant trees like he doesn't
believe in
trees someone needs to blow this guy I
volunteer his tribute I'll jump on this
grenade I don't know what I mean between
and then I guess he owns half of the
McDonald's uh potatoes for the french
fries Bill Gates gets real about climate
change planting trees is complete
nonsense but the end of the oil and gas
era is finally in sight planting trees
is complete
nonsense you don't think planting trees
is good aren't plet trees don't they
make oxygen how would it be nonsense to
have something that filters carbon
dioxide and makes oxygen I think he's
done too much of that appeal claim
circling that Microsoft founder Bill
Gates supports chopping down 70 million
Acres of trees but the truth is more
complicated oh oh is it what's
complicated shock there's a video of him
like being very glib about
it yeah promoting deforestation okay
cool cool cause well I think he kind of
wants to regulate the weather right the
startup company there a unique concept
for the removal of trees to protect
California
Forest